[Music]
bookmaking has evolved over time from
Scrolls to writing on sheets of paper
bound together to the invention of the
printing press people continue to
develop new ways of recording history
today thanks to digital technology the
possibilities of recording the spoken
word are endless a fine bookmaking
specialist makes just a few
limited-edition books per year using
traditional printing and binding
techniques production begins with the
case of tiny brass moulds one mold
called a matrix contains letters numbers
and punctuation marks a type casting
specialist inserts the matrix case into
a machine called a mono type composition
caster and melts lead alloy ingots in
the machines gas heated pot
[Music]
guided by a computer the machine casts
one character at a time for every word
of the book the computer program assigns
a location code to every matrix to cast
a character the program communicates a
specific code through plastic tubes
while puffs of air aligned that
characters matrix with the injection
nozzle the nozzle dispenses molten lead
into the matrix while the machine ejects
the cast character onto a tray called
the galley as the lines of text exit the
Machine the typecast specialist inserts
a strip of lead to create spacing called
letting between each line he transfers
the galley to the press room where a
proofing press spreads ink on the type
he places a sheet of newsprint over the
galley and releases an impression roller
the roller prints the characters onto
the paper generating a proof
meanwhile a typesetter assembles the
larger display copy manually by placing
individual letters into a composition
stick this method was used for all copy
prior to the invention of the automatic
type casting machines in the 1890s books
printed in large sizes of type must be
made entirely by manual typeset once
complete multiple galleys that make up
several pages of the book are placed in
a steel frame called a chase and loaded
into the printing press this cylinder
press feeds one sheet of paper at a time
to grippers that pull the paper around a
cylindrical roller as the roller rotates
the paper drops onto the ink type
printing the characters into the sheet 1
press sheet typically contains 8 pages
per side another machine folds the
sheets then bookbinders manually collate
groups of 16 consecutive pages to form
sections of the book called signatures
next a bookbinder shows the signatures
together one at a time until the book is
fully assembled this method of book
binding called Smith's own binding after
its 19th century inventor is of the
highest quality because pages can't fall
out or be removed
like the binding the book cover is
meticulously handcrafted a bookbinder
hot glues a piece of cloth to the back
of the cover the cover is made of
flexible paper and thick cardboard then
she flattens the cloth on all sides
using a razor blade the book binder
makes a slit for the cloth or she'll
place a recessed label later this
enables the cloth to spread out and form
to the spines rounded shape the cloth is
pressed firmly against the structural
components with a plastic tool called a
bone
another book binder attaches the cover
to the bound pages called the book block
first she applies glue to both
components
then she positions the book block on the
cover and presses them together
she places the book in a nipping press
that puts pressure around the spine
fusing the book block and cover together
then the front and back of the cover are
glued to the first and last pages of the
book the book then sits in another press
overnight bringing this bookmaking story
to a close
[Music]